our next guest has a rescue dog named
Murphy and it's none other than Jon Hamm
ers
[Applause]
I'm so excited to meet you I love you so
much
healing is mutual oh my God thank you
will you tell us about Murphy
he's the best he's the best oh see I
mean give me a break
give me a break what a distinguished
gentleman he very much
but he's he's got he knows his angles
I'll tell you that much you know now
Douglas comes back out he's like wait a
minute Murphy what are we doing here
Murphy's got like makeup on too she's uh
he's a very fancy lad he uh he sits with
his arms crossed all the time uh and
he's a uh he's a Mastiff mixed with
about three other things Rottweiler and
a bunch of other things so he's about 90
pounds and he's two and a half years old
so it's like having a a 800 pound
toddler like it's just like he walks
into things like he'll be looking the
other way and just walk into a car you
know like oh I didn't see that car there
uh sorry about that toddler or like
senior yeah I mean he's he's thick but
he he's got the brain of of a
five-year-old well we know that you love
rescue dogs Douglas is here today to
represent and I love rescue dogs I've
been a big rescuer my whole life and I
thought it'd be fun if we could play a
game that we've never played here before
but I'd love to inaugurate with you okay
it's called pop quiz
[Applause]
all right here's how it works we have
rescue dogs and they have questions on
them and they're also very adoptable and
very adorable our first representative
come on out Kela
oh my goodness
um oh my gosh oh my goodness Gila bear
how are you number one Douglas I swear
are you kidding me
um okay
um first question uh was there a part
that you most wanted but didn't get
funny story was that I auditioned for a
movie called Deep Impact I don't know if
you remember that oh I love that movie
it was one of the competing asteroid
hits Armageddon was the other one yes
indeed but I auditioned for it and I got
all the way down to the end and I was
like I'm gonna get this it's gonna be
great we got a movie and I didn't get it
uh John Favreau got it
but it was it was awesome he's such a
good guy well thank you so much I know
Keela well I mean
I was gonna I know he loves the Applause
okay well next up we have Ajax here
there's a lot of sniffing happening
which is important
um what is your best packing tip may I
ask oh I'm a good Packer but I'm also
good at putting things in the in the
trunk like of a car oh yeah like I'll
I'll make it fit are you like Tetris
kind of yeah and I feel like that's the
that's the secret to packing your
suitcase get it into the corners first
listen I'm telling you you think it
sounds like a no-brainer but when you
put stuff in the corners first then you
got all the middle and then that that's
the easy part to fill
thank you Ajax you did such a good job
oh and now we have Bentley's turn thank
you nice thank you Bentley
um well what's the craziest thing a
woman has ever done to get your
attention as Bentley just licks your
face
I've had a woman come up to me and ask
me to sign her baby
[Laughter]
sign your bait with a sharpie permanent
no it's a baby it's got skin like baby
skin that's terrible
oh Bentley finally it's uh it's it's
Bridget
um Bridget's a tripod by the way oh
Bridge yeah she's got three legs you're
three fur what is the weirdest and or
worst nickname you've ever had well when
your last name is ham
you get a lot of lunch meat related
situations there's a ham and cheese ham
and eggs it's just at a certain point
you make your piece with it you know if
you're named after a lunch meat you make
your piece with it uh but Zach
Galifianakis famously said a version of
the same question like don't you wish
you had a different last name like what
if your name was Stewart turkey link and
I was like
that's not better Zach but it was it was
uh you know I I'm I've made my piece
with my particular last name I mean I it
ham and cheese and ham and eggs I don't
feel like it's the worst you know I mean
I've heard some nicknames about you oh
care to share I think you covered it on
Stern okay
um
uh which was so fun yeah go ahead and
dig that one up guys yeah
that was fun have you I'm sure you've
done that yeah in fact oh my God
beautiful interviewer like it's it's
nice to talk to him he's got a
reputation you know the reputation of
when he was within the old days when it
was kind of Lawless and all bets are off
but now he's very thoughtful
uh human being a very nice guy
and a wonderful artist
have you ever seen his artwork no I know
you know Nan obviously one of our mutual
friends and Nana Jimmy Fallon my partner
of almost 30 years because the woman
named Nancy she ended up marrying Jimmy
Fallon now she's Nancy Fallon
um no I know they're close and
apparently he's this incredible artist
unbeliev unbelievable weirdly after I
did the interview he he called me to say
thank you and I called him back and he's
like I want to send you some show you
some of my paintings and I was like is
this a joke this is like a bit like am I
gonna get like some very lewd paintings
or something is it weird and no they're
like these gorgeous uh like Landscapes
and watercolors and everything I was
like remember I'm not expecting that
when George Bush like revealed his
paintings too they're they're great I'm
like when do people have time to paint
time to do this that is not a skill set
I got a full-time job and yet I guess
he's it's like brings him peace I have a
weird history with Howard Stern like he
used to pick at me in public okay um
over my mom where I was like you are
literally picking at like my deepest
wound publicly and he was he was such a
shock jock and yeah you said the word
Lawless which was so interesting and you
know I he was very triggering for me and
watching him not lose the essence of who
he is and the things we love about him
while he's gone to therapy while he's
become a husband and a father and in my
opinion one humble man's opinion one of
the most important journalists and
interviewers who are living on the
planet you're correct you're correct
it's extraordinary to watch his journey
I'm going to take Bridget I'll give
Bridget back I know now God I feel like
a villain now
um
I actually I'd like to uh play something
for you okay shoot hi John it's Kiernan
your Forever TV daughter here so I guess
everyone has their own specific little
box of memories and and my question is
do you have a memory of the two of us
that you care to share that you find
particularly special or hold fear also
hi I miss you
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a picture of Kiernan from this
first season when she was six years old
sitting on my lap in a like ballerina
outfit tutu looking up at me like this
and I that's only what I think of when I
think of Kiernan so like seeing her at
22 now I'm just like nope you are
forever six that's it you did not grow
up I fully uh dad to that because I was
at her like 20th birthday we had we took
pictures in her photo booth I was like
how are you 20 and her actual parents
were there and I was like commiserating
with them sort of like sitting around
being like can you believe our our
little girls all grown you're a little
girl but my also it's it's it's so it's
such a crazy experience but yeah we had
you know we started that show when she
was six and we went the better part of a
decade so she was 16 when we finished it
was crazy she is why is
extraordinary human being she's a great
kid
[Music]